a long time ago they say some old
southern King enslaved are giants by
magic and forced them to build your
famous wall then he kicked all of my kin
to the other side and raised an army to
keep us there and we're the uncivilized
ones wildlings Matt be sir King was wise
even a giant can be made to new but only
if he wants a better crack at your head
the free folk don't follow a man because
his father tells us if the king's son
was brave and strong hi we'd follow him
as if he did his father if he wasn't
but he seems to me as much as the wall
keeps us out and keeps you southerners
in you follow laws you didn't make kneel
to Kings you didn't choose and pray to
gods you never hear from her traders
talk about your seven beyond the wall
the stars shine bright and clear honey
God's errand listening to the likes of
men our gods are of the forest in the
trees that shelter us in the rivers that
feed us they gave the land for all of us
to share we fish farm and hunt where we
will when we need if a man wants a woman
he has to prove he'll give her strong
and cunning sons I was easy when she
tries to slit his throat he don't let
her with a free frock you get what you
can take and you keep what you can hold
no more I wonder even if Mike and in hop
over your wall but he still set your
nuts watch to guard it you saw the nose
a rich you always have more steal gold
and daughters I think you're afraid
if you've always knelt you don't know
what freedom is and if you've not been
beyond the wall you don't know what fear
is you will
you